hey guys my name is just module 8 is the
13th of August today and this is James
what news first up Bioware has announced
the next story driven RPG at Gamescom
shadow realms will have a modern fantasy
setting and is a multiplayer-focused
online game the RPG will revolve around
cooperative competitive for v1 gameplay
where four players work against another
player who takes on the role of the
enemy known as the Shadow Lord a story
involves a group of awakened heroes who
set out to fight against the shadow
legions of Umbra fire where austin
general manager Jeff Hickman explains
shadowrealms is a new Bioware RPG that
has the hallmarks of all Bioware games
with a restore a unique world setting
and deep combat progression but built as
an interactive experience that evolves
the genre and broadens the appeal to
online gamers all over the world it's
set to be episodic in nature will be
online only obviously and will launch in
late 2015 for pc you can head to the
games website to sign up for the closed
alpha right now if you'd like Microsoft
have decided they're the little guy
after telling Game Informer we are the
underdog Xbox hotel Spencer spoke about
the console war saying at some level it
is a competition and I've said before I
want to win at the same time I want to
build a great platform for gamers if
somebody else does that too and they do
really well hats off to them but I can
have success in our own space if we're
selling a lot of consoles and people are
buying games aside from Spencer again
proving that he's a pretty genuine and
logical human being he went on to say
that he noticed the Xbox one is being
beaten but in his eyes the real battle
will take place between September and
December of this year it seems that
enough angry voices may actually be able
to clear the air since Microsoft have
come out to say that rise of the Tomb
Raider will not stay Xbox exclusive
forever just for a period Phil Spencer
told Eurogamer that the deal has a
duration and that Microsoft did not buy
the IP for all time regardless he
wouldn't specify how long the deal
is between them and the developer
crystal dynamics due to the business
side of the agreement he did understand
the negative fan reaction though saying
if I'm a PlayStation person all of a
sudden I feel like the franchise is gone
I didn't buy the IP I didn't buy the
studio it's not mine where this thing
will go over time just like dead rising
3 or rise we'll see what happens with
the game plus up metal gear solid 5 is
coming to the PC starting with ground
zeroes and followed by the fans and pain
post games are set to come to steam
which was revealed via a leak on Konami
official site and was later confirmed by
series creator Hideo Kojima you can see
both games on Steam right now and add
them to your wish list the pc fans among
you are pretty jazzed about the news
although Kojima did tease the
possibility of metal gear solid 5 coming
to the platform back in March when he
said pc that's my original background i
originally created pc games a long time
ago i didn't want to rely on platforms
to release games so if people want it i
cannot make a formal announcement but
that is definitely something that i
would like to do must be a question of
the day let me know if you're most
excited to play rise of the Tomb Raider
shadowrealms or the phantom pain that is
it for me today I'll be back to her with
more new things to throw at your face so
be sure they're join me then